we might be drunk
we
might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
hello
good morning vietnam
happy holidays folks kwanzaa hanukkah
boxing day monica's over ah [ __ ] it's
been over it's over yeah damn when this
comes out yeah that eight days came and
went yeah yeah um oh hey we gotta
introduce our guests why don't you tell
the people who's sitting over there a
boy another new orleans native a [ __ ]
killer yes one of the best storytellers
in the game
our buddy dressed as santa
somewhat yeah sean padden hey we're here
we're here we're here santa's mechanic i
know right
he fixed the sleigh
sometimes he lets me drive you know
oh he's getting old he's getting old if
santa were real
would it be like a would it be like a
dread pirates roberts
thing
remember the dread pirate roberts no
i've never heard that's two [ __ ]
gentlemen who fancied themselves as
comedic
uh almanacs the the princess bride okay
i've never seen it you've never seen the
princess bride and i have another one
i've never seen i know i know i've
gotten [ __ ] for this
and i and i see a lot of movies so
that's a pretty big one that i'm missing
but that's like the that's a classic
princess pride yeah you're gonna love it
and i've seen my dinner with andre so i
really should have seen
i really should have seen the princess
grinder and you're a wrestling guy
aren't you no yeah i like wrestling i'm
not like a wrestling guy
i know i know you're i know you're a msg
guy i feel like they do wrestling there
that's true i feel like you spend a lot
of
time in the garden
i'm doing i should say i'm doing the
drinks today because the beer jew is
gone what happened to the beer jew he uh
he picked up a job he we can't we're
recording later in the night we can't
always do during the day we got [ __ ] to
do and
sometimes tell the folks what you're
you're cooking up here i'm making uh a
samurail's famous manhattan
i'm not measuring it
looks this looks more like a call as a
staten island by the end of the night
call this a hoboken
sam sam moral made us a hoboken
remember when you thought i thought you
i used to think long island iced teas
were classy oh i was like where were you
born myrtle beach
dude
i well because you because it looks
classy it's it's in the package it's
classy yeah yeah umbrella in it
sometimes i mean
yeah
i agree well i said this earlier mark
and i okay so mark grew up in like the i
i always say you grew up in like the
alphabet city of new orleans right okay
and i grew up in like the staten island
yes oh yeah i've heard you say that yeah
like the but but equal parts
kind of
i wouldn't call this white trash but i
like to call it white recyclables
we can be repurposed yes here here but
still
like i also remember thinking wine
coolers yeah we're like hey you're
[ __ ] you're on top of your [ __ ] if
you're pounding wine coolers yeah when
you drive your kids to school
[Laughter]
old english was a big one here
wait do you ever think wine coolers are
like looking at shelters being like [ __ ]
you
i was doing this yeah i was doing this
30 years ago that's true way ahead of it
yeah yeah i just went down to nola for
turkey
and uh i went to the i went on a gator
tour what i just said [ __ ] it i'm going
back to my roots i saw you post this
what is that you get on a fan boat you
go to the swamp and see gator it's like
a safari
did they have the guy with the did he
have the uh
the little ice chest
the ice chest strapped to the front of
it with bungee cords yes and he opens it
and just pulls out raw not not raw
chicken breasts like dead half chickens
oh yeah is he doing that oh yeah and
just throwing them out there to like you
can see you see the gator come swimming
up yeah it was exciting did you pretend
you were looking for brian laundry
i should have
damn but no no it was just great now i
hadn't gone since i was like five
so uh there it is oh [ __ ] you gotta pull
it up oh it's on my instagram but uh i
mean talk about [ __ ] ass and the new
orleans accent out there it's a whole
another it's you said it best it's a
brooklyn accent with a xanax yeah yeah i
gotta i just got i just gotta back you
up right now because they're [ __ ] the
internet's gonna eat you alive oh please
you just dropped you just dropped tunas
i promise you that is a phrase that has
nothing to do with race it's a cajun
hillbilly it's a cajun hillbilly yes i
have heard mark just drops the n-word
we're like that was right
but [ __ ] i dude that i said that once
in a like i'm talking 10 years ago
a little more oh wait yeah please oh
wait is that
you made i wasn't even what you shooting
the [ __ ] about gator meat and you
already whipped us up some
i'm still worried about the amount of
bourbon you poured in there but oh boy i
got three shows tonight
maybe
oh i might only be able to do four of
them
got three shows i got three shots i
might only do four
thank you sir i said that one hey thank
hey sam thank you sir can you do the
nola accent i'm talking the hardcore
heavy dude you gotta like it's just sort
of like you gotta drop
i feel like you gotta drop all your
words back in the back your mouth oh
hey cheers hey cheers to y'all mazel tov
hey happy holidays merry christmas happy
holidays you know wait i think it's
pretty good um
so is that good oh that's very good
that's very [ __ ] good oh it's great
yeah really nailed it
i mean it's good because i could tell
i'm going to be sh
i know right i got to get my act
together
look at that come on you can't that's
excitement on the fan boat down by the
bayou
looking for them gators
down there on the way yeah yeah you're
down there only a chaff a liar
uh there he is are you driving no i was
next to the guy though
what uh when did you move here sean how
about how long before mark same here you
move no you were first i mean i got here
before you but i was the ambassador i
think i got here in march and then you
got you and zach september y'all got
here like september yeah same year sims
yeah yeah funny funny guy phenom out of
the gate he was like 15 doing comedy i
remember from open mics in new orleans
yes i remember he had a bit about he
he's he's a he's a guy uh
he's like did you do [ __ ] open mics
in new orleans when you went to tulane
yeah i knew while bill dyke said yeah
come on look at this
wait when were you at tulane uh i was a
freshman the the year katrina happened
so i think oh five five all right so i
was already gone i was already all right
i was here for 9 11. i was there for
katrina yeah bro
somebody hate me move him to china
is that he's moving to wuhan
am i right am i right am i right people
on the right you [ __ ]
he's got a summer home in columbine all
right
every time he goes to la oh [ __ ]
we outslide
no we dude it was uh those open mics
lucy surfer bar that was classic that
was it that was i started with jill i
knew that
neil and i i moved up in here in march
neal moved right like a few weeks later
we me and neil stasny shared a bedroom
in two separate apartments wow over the
course of two years and living in
brooklyn ruined our friendship it sucks
yeah i love neil i'll always love him
he's a great joke writer i hope he's
doing well but it [ __ ] it'll just you
know
living with another dude for two years
in two separate apartments it's tough
sharing a bedroom yeah i'll [ __ ] with
you bedroom
yeah
holy [ __ ] well you see a side of people
it's just being roommates you see a side
of people that you're like all right
this it's a different friendship i mean
yeah like i mean he saw a side of me
that probably no one should see i mean
i'm a fat snoring slob and he had to
damn so
you shared one room and you snore
oh he snores like a wilder beast you got
the cpap right yeah i have a cpap now
thank god i have a cpap that doesn't
truly work it just numbs it it brings my
snoring from like a 10 to like a
five
people outside doing construction like
keep it down yeah we stayed in the
denver convo condo together you know the
denver coast comedy works which is yeah
it's like a tuna it's a two bedroom two
it's here it's huge can they get ceiling
or can they get walls that's where they
get you so i'm there with it
i hear his little feet dangling across
the hallway every time he gets up it was
ari jolis steve simone and me and him in
the condo at one point at five in the
morning we all came out with like night
caps on and a candle going this [ __ ]
guy we gotta kill him we thought about
killing we're standing over you yeah
with spears like lord of the first what
happened with mike racine i mean we did
mike is a horrible snorer and we would
we would share hotel rooms early on and
i was like i want to [ __ ] kill this
guy he was also in a bad relationship at
the time so you know when you have that
check-in call when you're like fighting
with your girlfriend and you're like i'm
gonna take a walk and do this call yeah
he would just have it right next to me
i'd be like dude you gotta like go
somewhere yeah he's very italian
well um no like the only snorers can
only share like canaan and i have shared
rooms
and we're both snorers
but we've shared can me canadian but
there's been other comedians like the
next morning they're just like bloodshot
eyes like you guys ready to go or what
you're like oh you've been up all night
because we're [ __ ] tag teaming you
yeah with our [ __ ] hunk shoes with
the booze throw that on top of it yeah
[Music]
i mean it sucks man it sucks because
also i i know like i have a i'm in a
almost eight year relationship and i
know my snoring is
you know it's probably not as good as it
should be because of that what's his
name
all right
what uh
what what causes snoring why do people
snore i mean for me it's probably 40
because i'm fat i'm just i'm just gonna
beat i'm just gonna beat all the
[ __ ] online to the punch here
because i'm a fat [ __ ] because i drink
too much because i'm gay because i'm
because i'm gonna snore too and i'm not
fat do you know man you've had girls
leave me
what yeah i mean i faked snoring so they
would leave
but that's why you wanted me to coach
you
that's why i did all those snore
coaching sessions
but no i'm a bad you know what you
turned into a punchline when you become
the like snoring grandpa though like my
grandpa would snore and he would just
like be in his chair snoring now we
would just laugh it was hilarious yeah
wait okay is the thing though do you
snore i don't not that i know of that's
you don't yeah i mean do you do either
of you or either of you burrowers in the
sack though do you move yes i do
because i find snorers often stay one
hundred percent put until somewhere you
got that going so yes there's the stormy
yeah you're stormy
i'm stormy daniels you know i'm scared
you're banging
trump in
in bed every night every night it's
rough but you're a lanky son of an onion
so you must be you're like one of those
guys outside of a used car lot you know
you're all limbs
dude i sold a dodge neon i uh no i'm
moving in the car out from the car in
the bed a lot and i i get up to pee a
ton so i'm one of those oh damn i got to
pee a lot if we if we the three of us
were in a spaceship that flew into like
a
cosmic event that turned us all a
radioactive event that turned us all
into super heroes you would definitely
become the stretchy guy yes
right right right
who are you what is mark yeah what am i
though am i flaming i think you're the
flame guy
a chair just develops a bunch of vaginas
those couches turn into [ __ ]
we just start [ __ ] the couches off
where are they
the building's on fire they're just
[ __ ] couches
no wonder bill cosby shop at sleepy's
all right
is that what it's called sleepies yeah
there's like that's a mattress store
that's what i was looking for yeah you
know what i like most about this drink
this little [ __ ] bad bat i know
that's not me that's the b that's the
beer jew who brings it he brings in the
nice uh i believe this is him isn't it
yeah yeah it's for the cherries
yeah i mean dude i manhattan i like a
you ever have a voucher
that's a new orleans yeah can you look
that up man
it's almost like uh it's like a
manhattan with absinthe sort of oh
absent is like the devil's uh that's the
devil's
saliva over you doesn't work though oh
you'll see [ __ ] and you're like no i'm
just hammered no yeah well they only say
that because i think uh previously
uh before there was administrations to
monitor how much booze was actually in
booze there was absinthe batches that
were just like 170 proof right so people
would have two cocktails i'd be like oh
i'm seeing [ __ ] i was like no you're
actually not seeing [ __ ] yes because
you're so [ __ ] up you can't focus they
do that on movies too with a guy will go
and then it's like whoa
and all this [ __ ] like that never
happens i just turn inward i hug my
knees like cry what i've never seen you
guys have done if you've done an
illusion
yes do you remember you've never done an
acid or true we've talked about this
before okay well if you ever want to
alex is mark is pushing me to do it on
the podcast which is a hard no no i'm
not busting my cherry on the podcast
can i tell you oh it's so fun i've never
done shrooms with mark but i've been so
two years ago maybe to whatever 2019
we're in
uh [ __ ] salt lake city yeah and it's
bert
arie
renaisseezi o'neal o'neil
me that's where i gave you that uh
std oh in the band the tub yeah we all
got we all got no no i was the only one
who didn't get it oh because i didn't
they all got in the hot tub and all got
a rash and i didn't get to i was the
only one with you i had a rash cooking
and we got in the tub and we all got i
was the only one no i got no i got it i
think day two or something i didn't i
didn't have enough exposure i was
rubbing my [ __ ] on your pillow i didn't
tell you
well there was that last gave everyone a
rash apparently well it was not a rash
it was uh what do you call it uti yeah
uti yeah i had a wicked uti that hurt ah
you get used to it
yeah you know you know not you don't
have to enjoy pee and it's quick
you know it's like giving birth you do
it because you have to there you go
cause you're biologically programmed to
get this thing out of your crotch but
the [ __ ] you know it transferred via
hotdog that was news to me well you
remember you everyone they were you all
took shrooms oh yeah the last night that
was amazing and we just were like we're
in we're just in the [ __ ] condo or
whatever the airbnb and mark's just like
popping up giggling places yeah so you
just be chatting and mark would just
appear right there it's like
it was so [ __ ] funny like you just be
like forget that you're in the kitchen
eating you're like i know right i mean i
eat this [ __ ] all the time and mark like
ah me too like where the [ __ ] did you
come from yeah michelle wolfe told me
that she shroomed with you once and i
bonded and she said that mark was like
she described him as a cat he would just
show up from time to time run away and
you'd be happy and then he'd run away
yeah yeah yeah you said that about a
tell once i remember the hell was like a
cat at the sa he was at the cellar he
came over to say hi and i like asked him
one too many questions and he ran and
walked away and you were like you scared
him off he's a grumpy cat
he's like a bodega cat you you pet him a
couple times then he just runs away
you're like yeah just be happy for the
moment
gotta be happy you gotta tell for a
minute he's over there spraying
he's over there spraying on something
right
yeah ah this smells like iced coffee and
cigarettes in a filter i love it i can't
believe you gave people a rash and a hot
tub that's like it's so weird to get
that in a place where you relax
oh yeah good point that sucks my arm my
argument's also that that hot tub was
definitely not vetted before for sure it
was an airbnb hot tub that could have
been the [ __ ] and had six sweaty
drunk guys in it drunk
drunk comedians yeah that's also
that's where you mentioned uh blowing a
guy yeah i don't know if that was
supposed to go out in the airwaves
that's that's it yeah i i i've had one
here we go this is this this is that all
right we can edit
editing is for the week wow that's a
t-shirt
now do we let him know i was the guy you
blew or no
yeah
that's when you mentioned blowing a guy
when you were blowing me right
sorry about that right no i mean there
was there was it was uh 2013
right right i'm [ __ ] you know the year
of [ __ ] yeah 2013. uh right after i
filmed uh half an hour my comments after
half hour uh-huh we were we were at the
after you know you've done did you do
you what what you where did you do yours
boston all right so it's boston it's
okay same here the royal theater same
place uh you remember afterwards we're
all at the w just getting
[ __ ] wrecked can
you know in the comedy central suite
then we got kicked out of there yep and
then we just they kept doing the thing
where like 20 of us went to another
person's room then only seven of us went
to another person's room and then four
of us and then ended up being me and
this he was one of the he was one of the
employees that's all i know and he was
like an attractive dude who i could tell
had been like flirtatious towards me
he's a hunk you know yeah i know the guy
yeah he tried to blow me i said no
because i have a little self-control
yeah but uh he's a good-looking guy
but i was at that point where i was like
huh single
why the [ __ ] not do this
why not just give it a go wow so like
how open-minded yeah i'm very you're not
giving ahead you're receiving heads what
not i did we both
both have
because it was in that moment where i
was like i have to know
i have to like
i'm going for it you know
yeah i know right now
yeah
well i didn't know you blew him i
thought he blew you
you said
you said it in the setup you were like i
did not know you blew him i was joking
well this changes it was a very specific
type of homophobic i mean i just had no
idea
what uh getting a phone call
[Laughter]
i want my son to be a catcher not a
receiver damn it i look at it i look at
it like like visiting i don't know like
you visit a place where you're like oh
that was interesting i i see why people
are into it not for me all right or like
a dish
if it were a place where would it be
um atlantic city
uh miami that makes sense you know what
i mean like i get it i get why people
love it but just uh not my not my
analogy that's good i i had a gay thing
with a kid when we were seven we made
out for a while and i yeah yeah yeah
we were seven years old i mean i was at
uh you know all boys school so it was
prison gay but uh
no we you know we yeah for sure why did
young even make out with a woman well
yeah i mean that's the thing is like you
can't you can't physically really go
further right your dick doesn't get hard
good you know you're limited i feel like
it doesn't get soft at that age
i feel like i had a boner until i was
14. really
this is your superpower
some people remember their first boner i
remember the first time like why is it
soft will it ever be normal again
that would be that'd be like everyone
always gets like superpowers like you
know in those movies what if there's a
guy who just can't knock it hard he's
always second he comes he's hard again
he's like [ __ ] this is my life this is a
viagra man
you kind of help with the villains he
tries to run by you trip him
you know it's a dick
tripwire took me a second it was good if
we were an improv group
that would have been i'd be out
that would have been like guys we're not
we're not just handing mark here that
must be the hardest part you never think
about it improv groups they must kick
people out sometimes yeah enough i'm
sure
that must be tough oh yeah
where do you go from there yeah i've
seen i have seen i have seen good improv
same but it's like it's you could tell
it's [ __ ] who've been together for
a decade yeah and just hang out all the
time i mean technically in many ways a
podcast is just improv true yeah you
know what i mean we're just like
hoping to get something good out of this
we're all laughing together we're like
listening we're talking and there's just
no like well i'm a
i'm a mad professor right right and i
demand you give me your firstborn child
give me a location where you should be
there's none of that you just go
you're not getting any audience you know
i forgot about that part which is never
you know todd glass yeah he's my [ __ ]
one of my [ __ ] favorites
so what i love about todd so
crowd work i think crowd works fun and
all but i feel like a lot of times
crowdwork is essentially just repeating
whatever they just said back to you in a
different tone where you're like where
are you from like oklahoma like oklahoma
and people like ah
they acknowledge the person yeah but
todd but there's some people who are
excellent at that [ __ ] but todd does
this other level of crowd work where
it's almost like he's taking what the
audience is saying and then putting it
into his the [ __ ] crazy comedy
machine that is his brain and he's being
like what if so i saw him once in l.a he
was like wait are you guys do you guys
do so do you do you do improv comedy are
you guys improvisers and one of the guys
like i do he's like it's crazy right
because when you ask for suggestions
it's [ __ ] you don't you don't really
care what they say you already have a
thing planned you already do he's like
what if i did that what if i was the i'm
a stamp comedian here's what was going
to happen and they gave us the audience
the script he's like i'm going to ask
for a suggestion no matter what you say
i'm going to hear bulldozer all right
so he comes in he like leaves the stage
comes back out and he's like all right
guys i'm a one-man improv group i need
well i need a suggestion of a machine
that's used on a construction site and
people are just yet railing random [ __ ]
he goes i heard bulldozer and then he
starts [ __ ] doing it and it was just
like oh man
that's a level of like comedy that i
miss seeing more of silly not silly or
just like taking risks
way off in left field right right where
like now and it's very meta right i mean
you're kind of very meta and i try i
know i tend to lean that way sometimes a
lot of comedians still do that a lot but
i also feel like there's a pressure now
because comedies now i don't know if
they're [ __ ]
like telling kids at 14 years old or
younger like you could be you're funny
you should start doing comedy when
you're
when you hit puberty yeah like there's
just the bigger middle class of comedy
that's ever been it used to be like
you're true you're joan rivers or you're
like a struggling road comic yeah and
now it's like there's a lot of people
making a living at this sure kind of you
know in the world or
or it finally became respected as a
craft there's probably both
because i think because everyone
not everyone
like i think for the longest time people
didn't look at being funny as an actual
talent
that's true i think people were like oh
singing is a talent playing an
instrument's a talent acting i can't do
those things acting's a talent whatever
but i'm funny talent what i don't know
if it is i mean it's like being athletic
it's it's vague so it's a big umbrella
but if you are athletic and you get good
at basketball or why should i
because i read this book
sure yes you have to call it but i do
think you have to have it i agree you
have to have and i think the it is a
talent like you have to have like that
innate that ability to just
say something like do you remember the
first time you were ever funny
i remember some lines i had growing up i
vividly remember the first time really
it was ever funny what was it i was in
the sixth grade
and i was at holy cross school for boys
yeah yeah right
yeah that's where i went to middle
school it's where i eventually knew i
was going to blow a good dude one day i
guess wow but uh i beat you to the punch
i remember
i remember the remember how teachers
sometimes would let you just [ __ ] off
for the last 15 minutes of class
uh because good teams
yeah good teachers really seems to care
we always do the rodney voice do you
remember uh goodies headache powder yeah
so i remember our the teacher was
letting us [ __ ] goof off whatever and
he was putting goodies headache powder
in his drink and someone that one of the
students was like what is that he's like
it's headache powder i've been you guys
are driving me crazy i've been having a
pound or all you know whatever and i
just i remember instinctually just
raising my hand teacher called on me and
i went my uncle snorts goodies up his
nose
[Laughter]
and he
spit took it's the first time
and laughed his [ __ ] ass off and
everybody else just sort of laughed and
i didn't really even understand what the
[ __ ] i meant by that whoa
i just knew i had somehow ascertained i
loved it snorting small powder up an
adult's nose was something that they did
but weren't supposed to do a mature joke
for you right but i didn't understand
but i just remember being like oh this
would be funny yes and like there's and
that's a mild version i'm sure people
have way better versions and way funnier
comedians but i think you still have to
have that thing yes yes
and it had to come out right and you use
that at i think i think like
like athleticism everyone can be
athletic but not everyone is an athlete
does that make sense i agree same thing
with comedy yeah everyone can be
everyone can get better at it but yeah
it does you have to start somewhere
right to make a career at this point or
like any certain like anyone can be
funny in a certain situation but not
everyone can
be a comedian no does that make sense no
and i think that line has been blurred
lately where it's like oh yeah well no
you can do this you just have to move to
new york you have to be a comedian you
have to get past at the comedy cellar
yeah you have to get on leno or late
night orlando you have to have a photo
of you holding a microphone on facebook
right right right like you do one open
mic you could say i'm a comedian there's
a formula to it yeah but yeah but it is
interesting like also it it's great that
there's less gatekeepers but at the same
time absolutely but at the same time you
know bad [ __ ] bad [ __ ] always gets a lot
of views like there's that guy who you
know you see that guy bragging that he
got uh all those eyeballs over 100
million eyeballs because he did a squid
game like rip oh yeah that [ __ ] guy
and you're like okay but
but this dude had an actual id this is
the dude that had the idea you're still
not creative right right right you're
bragging that you are it's almost like
being a good businessman over being yeah
you know
that's that's
rewarded more than originality i agree
i'm a fan of the original i like that
and this guy's just kind of glomming
onto that but
you could say the same for weird al
yeah you know but i like weirdos but
we're allowed still weird al still
created he's still writing he's still
he's still and everyone and every single
one of you weirdos songs he parried he
he found a theme to his parody like even
his newer [ __ ]
like i think the best one he's done of
all of weird al's catalog so far even
though the point is they're weirdos
catalog i know right but he's got a
money that he's got the same word uh for
all his music as bob dylan yeah
absolutely
like if the weird hell is not inducted
into the rock and roll hall of fame
he will it will be a [ __ ] cry he's a
legend yeah but like i met him one
sweetest pie yeah he's awesome great i
mean i think some of his best work was
his later [ __ ] like the handy the making
fun making fun of the
the iggy azalea
the i'm so handy
you don't even know that but he raps as
a handyman
it's [ __ ] it's a great song it's good
i'm brilliant or like as bad as gold uh
dude uh gang uh amish paradise oh yeah
oh that might be he always found the
perfect like yep so silly i i always
liked word out a lot wait do you have an
old school zinger you said as a kid
cause i gotta i gotta yeah i mean
they're not that funny i mean something
when you're a kid they're just not okay
yeah okay i mean it was i literally
i was in second grade i got in trouble
with the teacher
and uh i just got on my knees and did
jim carrey in the mask you know the guy
when he's like did you do this i said it
wasn't me it was a one-armed man but i
did the jim carrey voice from the mask
and he laughed his ass off and it like
that got me out of trouble
you got her knees you were still four
four and a half feet tall
[Laughter]
you starting forward
i got on my knees i said just let me out
of trouble i'll suck your dick oh man
come on no i said uh no i did the jim
carrey voice and he was like uh he
laughed and
you see that [ __ ] and of course then you
start taking it too far because you see
that
when you get that laugh it is like a
drug you're chasing some [ __ ] right and
it's you it's hard to get that high back
when you're a kid and you know what the
[ __ ] you're doing yeah that's right
you know
theater or some [ __ ]
mine was uh my first birthday party i
made the uh the invitations you know you
had to hand write them out you know 50
of them or whatever and i wrote be there
be triangle
not great oh
hey dude that was
are you kidding me that's a [ __ ]
ah it's a tweet but
but then the big laugh i remember
getting was in like fourth grade
my teacher yelled we were learning about
expressions like what goes around comes
around and you know whatever it is and
she said now what do you not do in a
glass house and i said shower
kill oh that's a good launch it's
actually still good yeah it's like
killed but you could probably that could
end up on some of those comedy central
the little one-off thing that you just
made a meme out of it that was a good
one but here's the clinker after this
girl danielle
came up and she was like you were funny
today do that again tomorrow and i'm
being like
so you start to learn the power of
comedy yeah do that again tomorrow
that's the same that's the audience
remember you see before the show like
you better bring it tonight yes [ __ ] you
that's what it was just for that i'm
gonna phone it in and get drunk right
before the show wait is fat juice still
a thing that guy's still around i'm sure
either that or [ __ ] jerry there's all
those memes and stuff like jokes before
i got right like a year or so before
that whole thing when he stole that
dude's instagram thing i was in a movie
with
fat jew
mark maron wow eve
wow and
meta world peace wow this is like the
birthdays of the day dude such a random
news it's a [ __ ] it's a movie called
all wifed out i think it's only
available on itunes it's dog [ __ ]
probably but i never saw it but i
remember shooting it i was like this is
ridiculous but i was in every scene with
eve
and like two scenes with metal world
peace who can't [ __ ] act sorry
sorry meta love metadata that dude
thought he could act but he's a [ __ ]
legend that dude we're rolling legend we
love you mata yeah okay yeah but you
can't act but uh
but but he's a nice enough guy but
[ __ ]
fat jew that dude told me and he could
have been [ __ ] with me but it changed
my perception he was like all of the
hasidic jew neighborhoods in brooklyn
they're running ecstasy through oh
and and i was like what and he broke
this whole thing down where he's like
i'm telling you they have their own
police departments no one's going in
there that all ecstasy
flows through interesting
the acidic jewish neighborhoods in
williamsburg and crown heights and i was
like holy [ __ ] if that's true that's
kind of them that's kind of amazing yeah
that that's like that they're just like
women can't walk past
the purim thing not the pearl what is it
they gotta wear wear wigs no but what is
it that no they're weird with women
going out at night or something
what is it there's a time of year where
they can't have the the string the uh
oh the string that they can't i've seen
crosstalk the women can't leave the yes
or speak english in some situations hold
on we
this is going to be a [ __ ] dangerous
one the first thing that popped up was
women can do anything
yeah
yeah
yeah you ever heard of that i don't know
oh man not a good jew you can't cross
these lines but you can snort some lines
of molly yeah apparently molly steinberg
that's a girl i did did you really no no
i'm just kidding that'd be [ __ ] funny
have you ever dated a jew you like
jewish women i've had sex with many yeah
uh israeli by the way wow talk about a
tough cookie yeah my god she was she
would do a weird thing where i'd bang
her and then i'd finish and she'd go
leave it in wow
all right so we just be laying there i'm
like looking at my phone you know just
sitting there like am i good now
she's holding a little mark who's going
a triangle
triangle
but the whole time he's talking about a
vagina
right
wait but you're jewish sam right
but i'm not religious jacket i mean
yeah
i'm not a religious my girl my my my
partner is jewish is she really yeah
cook jewish name i know right now seems
so cool
her mom her mom's her mom's like like
legacy hollywood jews oh wow yeah um
different different different different
uh different style of jew out there yeah
yeah i get roll i get rolled up on a lot
uh by the the hasidic guy but it's like
are you jewish and i know i was like oh
no they always they always just
immediately be line i don't know i just
what if i say yes i just want to know
i'll come hang out no no no it's a trap
i did it once yeah i know i'm on the
street with ron on yesterday both jewish
uh yeah and they come up to us he jewish
we at the same time go no no we've just
been through it too long
and then liz at the seller's right next
to us and she's like i should have
yelled out i am like
uh relentless i did it once just to see
i had a minute i had nothing to do that
day and they took me off to the side did
a big prayer and they said a bunch of
like
hymns and whatever
and they smelled like [ __ ] and then they
circumcised me
but it was weird it took like 30 minutes
and they read me a bunch of passages it
sucked yeah that's what i should have
asked for i'm like can we do some mana
shavits
some shoot just to shoot a bottle of
menachevic yeah something these these
are [ __ ] good i got yeah they're very
good
the
the ice kind of makes it a little nice
it goes it's a little more it cuts it
cuts it a little yeah and i gotta slow
down this is good
wait what's this bourbon we're drinking
oh is this [ __ ] basil hayden's yeah
oh christ you know it yeah dude i did i
mean i did host a show about drinking
for two seasons that's right with jay
larson yeah yeah i love jay yeah i would
i did i did retain some [ __ ]
information i was forced down our
throats yeah you know and one of them is
that basically
i think that was a gift all right good
to know that's good [ __ ] now how hard is
it because we drink a couple times a
week for this show you had to drink what
every day
when we were filming we
would do like five days per city
and usually i would say three on average
three to four bars
per day wow it would be all day it would
be all day it would be in the end were
you just [ __ ] hammered dude i was
having like
i was having episodes where i was like i
would like wake up and not remember
where i was or who i was for like a few
years you don't want to blackout while
filming [ __ ] that's a badass
you don't want to black out while
sleeping that's the best way i could
describe it would be like i'd wake up
and have to piss or something and be
like where am i what's chicago chicago
wow sean sean john my name is sean like
it was just like i just like my brain
was so just inundated or
that that's not the right word there it
is what channel was the show on it was
on esquire they would play on the
airplane yeah what about uh what were
the best bars you were at i mean that's
that's the fun that's a fun question
because people will like ask me that
sometimes i'm like if you watch the show
you saw how [ __ ] hammered i was right
yeah i barely remembered any of it i
will say
i still believe this the best two
drinking cities yeah in the country are
new orleans and chicago oh
meaning that you can drink a lot or
meaning good bars meanwhile
meaning just meaning just like it's an
actual culture here like i love drinking
in new york yeah but there the bar scene
in new york is it's kind of homogenized
they're all you've been to one you've
been winning when's last call in uh new
orleans and there is no last call in new
orleans right okay the bourbon street
too okay what about chicago chicago has
everything from 2 a.m to 5 00 a.m
so there's bars that close at 2 a.m but
then there's as long as you have the
option for the after hour oh yeah yeah
yeah you can and and 5 a.m i think is
only on the weekends in chicago but you
can drink
every night of the week in chicago you
can find a place to [ __ ] stay that's
what they drink in chicago that shit's
disgusting
they made me do a shot of that they made
me like i had no choice they suggested i
do a shot of my lord during my last week
and also dude they have their own st
patrick's day in chicago that's a
[ __ ] drinking culture that's what i'm
saying it's a green river chicago's
great chicago's fun place drink i also
i'm an [ __ ] because i'll do that to
people in chicago i'll order shots on my
lark and be like guys we're doing around
the tequila
and not telling to come over there with
shots like hey cheers tell ya and then
everybody's like what the [ __ ]
my lord you just got me lord
you should have looked at it it's kind
of green yeah
[ __ ] is rough rough not good is it
it's almost like a licoricey uh cough
medicine
so caitlyn pointed this because i when i
met caitlyn she was living in chicago
but uh
they have an amazing marketing team so
there was a i think this is kind of
famous you can look this up there was a
billboard in uh in a chicago
neighborhood where one bill it was two
billboards next to one another one was
for cooked champagne and it was just two
glasses cheersing
and it said she just found out she's
pregnant oh right and then the next one
they melor bought the billboard next to
it and it was two shot glasses clinking
and the text was
oh no i'm sorry
strike that the the cooks once said she
just found out she's having twins the
milort one said she just found out
they're conjoined at the head
so like i love that so like
they like there it is yeah yeah yeah
right there right there yeah yeah
nice see that makes me want to have
twins that's what it is that's the power
they're funny i mean that's the thing
yeah i i just did a weekend in chicago
and uh
it's awesome yeah i did italia hall with
canain and it was [ __ ]
amazing yeah it's one of the best comedy
towns they uh
yeah they were telling me there that
people the milord advertising people are
cool as [ __ ] yeah they get it they get
it that the i mean that's a huge it
tastes like satan's balls dollars uh
shave club dollar shave club they were
all funny ads and that's why it blew up
funny stuff goes a long way especially
in the advertising and also chicago is
like
they're a cool city i mean honestly when
a city gets that cold
you p the people have to be cool dude i
say
humble
the midwest is my favorite part of the
country to do comedy in
i can see that because it's a cold
weather people are forced to develop
personalities it's so true because they
spend half the year inside i just hang
at a [ __ ] beach yeah it's a tundra
like i'm with you and i love but i also
love out here too like the midwest
northeast they're grateful too you know
other people because they get a good day
or a good it's a distraction from the
cold is tough it is it's hell well i
also feel like i love i love new york i
love certain rooms in like on the east
coast i also feel like you get too many
like
uh there's a there's a love of like edge
here on the east coast that can get a
little [ __ ] exhausting where you're
like
you just listen to what i'm [ __ ]
saying i'm not gonna be just because i'm
not saying certain words that
make you believe that i'm on your
[ __ ] level tough ass i thought you
get too many [ __ ] tough guy like ah
come on that's comedy's supposed to be
edgy i'm like is it it's supposed to be
funny you [ __ ] exactly i don't i i hate
that whole like a comedy's gotta be this
that the other thing it's like no it
doesn't it's just got to be funny i hate
that too dude the people that are like
because you know because i'll tell
sometimes i'll have like a joke that
people like that's a dark joke i bet you
like this guy and then they show me a
clip and he's like so i'm so [ __ ]
this baby
i don't like this [ __ ] i would actually
say to both of you yeah both of you are
very well
you're both extremely skilled at dark
subjects thanks
i watch a lot i don't know about you but
i i watch a lot of comedy and i just see
i don't want to be that guy i don't want
to do that i don't do that yeah edge
thing you want to play it well it's like
it's like a violin yeah you know you got
to know the instrument if you're looking
to be edgy it's it's dangerous because
you're you're
you're trying to do a thing rather than
be funny well right i look at it like a
joke is like a sword right if the edge
should be sharp but you also have to
have a spine and a blade and a grind and
a [ __ ] handle
and it's got the joke it's the blade
itself has to be well tempered and like
if you just focus on the edge part the
moment you try and strike something the
rest of the [ __ ] thing will shatter
because you weren't paying attention but
the edge should be there
but the edge is the
is actually the least important part and
only certain people can swallow it
exactly
and to all the people jumping on the
listen this guy didn't watch enough
blademaster do you ever see that you
remember that show no what was it called
blade masters
it was like a a sword it was a la it was
like a top chef for blackstone you got
matt doing a lot of google searches over
here blade master yeah there you got it
no that's not that that sounds like a
gay porn it was
filming at the w yeah oh there it comes
here comes the belching's coming bring
it on this is a belch friendly show
mark belcher's like how deep in rick and
morty are you now i'm getting i finished
the first season that's it i'm getting
there that was months ago
i [ __ ] i'm obsessed
uh he he was like they should have
called it master blader oh
way better good yeah that's good
bowen walker shout out to you bobo he
makes he's a he's a craftsman in denver
uh but what's your what's your favorite
drink when you're drinking with jay
would you was it a lot of beer what
would you do no the thing that was the
thing that sucked about that show was
that like we didn't have any creative
control
and that's the thing people would always
got like people got like legit mad at me
when i quit and not because they were
huge fans of the show because they were
like how can you walk away from such a
plot i'm like it wasn't plush man no we
we love drinking booze in general
because it's an escape but when it
becomes your [ __ ] job sucks good so
like you're drunk and like we couldn't
fake drinking on camera yes every now
and again we would tee up another shot
and not actually take it yeah because
we'd already done three you sure it was
like
2 30 in the afternoon kind of [ __ ] and
we still had to do and so like we would
act and even if you were faking it like
i am drinking this drink at a slightly
slower pace me too but i am already
drunk
because booze affects you well it's also
it's all bourbon i mean we're drinking
we just drank a [ __ ] i mean this has
got to be
thank you there's many
whiskeys yeah [ __ ] you're right i didn't
think but we would go to bars and have
to drink their craziest drink or their
most potent [ __ ] or do a shot of 50 year
old appleton rum san francisco was that
place rum wasn't very good tastes like
what newspaper how do you like san
francisco san francisco is a great
drinking city um yep you got the water
there san francisco is [ __ ] cool yeah
it's a cool city i wish it would [ __ ]
be taken away from the goddamn
tech people [ __ ] yeah
i have a guy i went to high school with
lives there him and his wife were both
doctors and they they had to leave they
couldn't afford to buy anything in san
francisco wow two ducks two doctors
couldn't buy man and then there's these
[ __ ] turds out here who like well
what are you gonna do man that's just
you know hey america you make money it's
always a guy like that who says that
[ __ ] who actually doesn't have any money
oh yeah the guy was always like whatever
dude they're just making money it's like
what are you worth
you know it's [ __ ] you just [ __ ] you
fantasize with them because you think
you're gonna [ __ ] be one of them one
day by siding with them you're not well
everyone thinks they're gonna be rich
that's the thing is like that's how
that's how
you get people is like no one's like
everyone no matter what your job you're
like i'll put it together yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'll figure it out
some will click
as you said that i'm like [ __ ] i didn't
know sam was filming my mantra
that's why bernie's got a hard time
bernie said we got to tax these [ __ ]
millionaires and everyone in the country
is kind of like that could be a
millionaire yeah it could be me
i mean dude the [ __ ] we got to stop
trying to elect barney start trying to
clone him
you know you get a young bernie like
this larry david yeah
i remember uh tim dillon called me like
three years ago he's like did you hear
they're taxing millionaires i'm like
you're doing a lot better than me
i just i was just in madison doing
uh
comedy on stage shout out fantastic one
of the questions one of the great
questions indeed i don't know i don't
know if there's anything better honestly
i put i i love enough to touch the top
of that club
oh dude i [ __ ] acme is up there in
minneapolis i love wise guys in utah
yeah but no i mean like he's like these
are the top of the [ __ ] helium
you're not gonna get the green room
comedy on state's amazing the hotel's a
block away the town saying that on the
podcast dude
you got weirdos walking back with you
uh i had that last point well but it's a
bit but you know the hotel is right
there across from the capitol
[Laughter]
you know it's right there it's the park
hotel
but
no it's a fanta it's a it's an amazing
club the family's awesome that runs it
there's
sister eva
they're amazing the sisters that are
awesome they're [ __ ] awesome the
whole place is amazing good people
really seem too good thank you it's
getting nervous well they care
that's all there is to it like they
they care about the business they care
about who they put on stage they care
about how you're doing and you know what
who they care about the least uh
[ __ ] who are like the customers
always right right they're like no we
care about customers who they come who
come in or like we enjoy comedy and want
to watch this yeah we've all had that
thing on stage at a funny bone or a
bonkers with a z and you go you got
you're gonna kick this guy out you're
gonna tase this [ __ ] he won't
shut up and then go he bought chicken
wings what do you want me to do and
you're like all right i was at
caroline's once and this guy would not
he was like a scary dude he would not
[ __ ] let up my whole show and i said
is someone gonna kick this guy out and
it was like a dude who looked like me
who was the bouncer of caroline's he
walked over and whispers to him and he
just looked up at me and goes he says no
i was like yeah right i guess i'm [ __ ]
exactly dude one of my favorite
comments say this is years back as i
show up
or between shows uh one of the manager
at the time was a guy named joe and he
was like hey man there's a table up
front they're a little hammered already
but we're watching them ah already
already so already
that table got thrown out at the end of
the feature set perfect right they got
them out so i get on stage right after
they and i'm like how about how about
that table huh and then no one was
sitting at the table i'm like it's kind
of a waste of kind of a shame does
anybody want to move up and there's a
bunch of applause
and then but one table was really
emphatic about it and i was like can
they move and from the god mic joe goes
it's fine so this table they move up
four people into this table and within
five or ten minutes they're now a
problem
that table is haunted so they get thrown
out and then i was like i think it's
this [ __ ] table and chairs i go can
we get this table and chairs out here
that's a joke but then they come down
the staff comes down like picks up the
tab stack the chairs and walk out
and i'm like trying not to [ __ ] lose
my [ __ ] laughing because i can't believe
they're doing they're that good but i'm
trying to play into it like yeah you
gotta get the i don't come to where
you're made and give you an extra leg
you know just i'm i'm blown away that
they're actually you know what you know
what honestly is always uh yeah that's
why it's a great one of the greats no
it's one of the greats and it's
something about like liberal cities in
red states
i don't even know if wisconsin's red
this time around i i forgot but uh it
was blue this time it was blue this time
but i think it's a purple state it's a
purple city but those when you get like
i mean you get like like lexington
kentucky great crowd right you're in a
red state but you got a broadway yeah
yeah or off broadway that's a good one
one of the best one of the most magical
room yeah it's a magical little room
there's a magical room where you just
you get people they just [ __ ] know
how they know you're kidding they know
it it's a which is so weird but like
yeah you guys
go north go up to right there go up to
go bananas that's a great club great
club is it it's not my favorite
it's a special pop yeah yeah
the room the room is electric but the
room i've taken some hard l's in that
room oh really i i don't know what it is
maybe it's you
maybe it's you is my next special title
maybe it's me what happened
uh no it's you know why because it's not
really i don't
it bugs me look the room's incredible i
met ron on hershberg there
to where we met like eight years ago
judah jew
of no way you're choosing kentucky that
one of my favorite jokes ever where he
said uh he said you know my grandparents
fled the holocaust and moved to kentucky
and uh people like a jew from kentucky
he's like yeah when they fled the
holocaust they weren't picky
that's a great joke uh kentucky's
underrated i think like louisville's
awesome yeah uh louisville louisville
yeah what are you [ __ ] kentucky's
great louisville is underway they're
opening a club the people who run uh
spokane and uh
bricktown's bricktown was breaking down
that was a surprise
also oklahoma city you're like oh that's
right weed's legal here
you forget that they have nothing else
to do
yeah i love how oklahoma has a rivalry
with texas where it's like if the two or
you were to actually fight
it would just be called north texas
i'm not trying to [ __ ] on entire stage
like kevin hart in the rock
it's not gonna happen but uh yeah they
and also it's like kind of a depressing
city okay see what they're like well
like what's there to do they're like we
got the bombing museum
all right
we also have legal weed now for you to
enjoy this yeah great barbecue in okc
sure great uh good people like they
really are people the crowds are [ __ ]
awesome at that club yeah yeah
and the uh the basketball team is good
even though it's all about bricks
they're not they're not good all right
they're bad right now that was it but
that was a good one that was a good
basketball joke that's good all right
it's good that's better than triangle
that's [ __ ]
dude
i sat at some restaurant there i'm like
shown before the show and some woman
just starts chatting me up an older lady
and she's telling me like her husband's
a musician he's some pretty famous
musician
uh yeah
[ __ ] albino guy [ __ ] minor yeah
albino musician victor vernado
albino we know
that movie is so bad i heard it's
horrible horrible movie i watched it
again over the pandemic just for fun and
it wasn't fun
you know when you do something just for
fun you're like oh this isn't fun at all
no it's [ __ ] [ __ ] up that's irony
it's just bummer black albino does that
help oh he's a black albino yeah all
right
lublino but i'll say this about albinos
you would think the kkk right there
you think the kkk would love them who's
wider
yeah i mean i'll say this about albinos
is a great album
i mean they're the whitest people i've
touched anything
i don't know i don't know who it is i'm
sorry wait who's that guy
yeah i [ __ ] up i i shouldn't have been
that brother
no steven
last thing i'll say about the comedy
club on state the two women who run it
their dad owns it he's this cool greek
dude two girls are beautiful women cool
as [ __ ] and they will get in someone's
face they're like these hot girls and
though one of them was on like one knee
like kaepernick style like you better
shut the [ __ ] up or you're going out of
here to some lady and they were like uh
[ __ ] you and they she threw her out
herself they've got that they've got
that like greek like you work for
everything yes yeah they like yeah it's
super badass yeah and they're fun they
drink with you i mean they got it all
they're good people for thanksgiving i
was losing too yeah thanksgiving we were
in chicago and we kind of didn't have
plans and uh chad daniels who
[ __ ] if you don't know his comedy
i think he's one of the most spin comics
on pandora he's an incredible joker
writer incredible and a great guy
good egg him and kevin bozeman you know
that guy i love those yeah so i've heard
he's incredible i've never seen him live
i've never had kevin boosman kevin that
was the thing they were like come up we
were in chicago they were like come up
to madison
and we'll do like a thanksgiving just
hang out during the day
and the moment we get there
chad we're just we're at a restaurant
[ __ ] chatting and chad's like what
are y'all doing tonight and i was like
actually we're gonna drive to dubuque i
had you know they're gonna let us in the
condo early because i was doing the
weekend after and chad's like oh you're
okay cool and then like three shots
arrive yep like he's like you're not
driving i already got you a hotel room
hotel room he's like i have points don't
worry about it i got points i got points
and then he [ __ ] gets i love rogue
comics yeah yeah and they're going to
dubuque these are all the markets we're
not hitting they take care of it yeah
yeah wait do you ever we ever been to
dubuque no where is it iowa it's like
it's like an hour and a half west of
madison it's surprisingly like chill
city okay a little pirates town what's
the guy who directed uh [ __ ] he's
directed a lot of movies the player
robert altman robert altman altman it
has a very robert altman's popeye like
shanty town oh i like it i was just
watching the criterion interview with
like matthew modine he's going through
all the closet things and he's it's like
you're like forget matthew dean's had
this awesome career oh yeah he's like oh
yeah i did shortcuts with uh robert
allman he's one of my and then he goes
to the next one he's like oh yes i've
worked with uh stanley my friend stanley
kubrick and you're like this dude's
[ __ ] live apocalypse now oh god yeah
no no uh full metal jacket sorry
exactly my bad uh yeah i'm just saving
you from the youtube commenter
oh yeah how about uh movies or movies
yeah dude there's something about the
play was a great movie that uh
i love we go to so many cities that are
just strip mall after strip mark when
you go to like a city with something
yeah we can walk around
i've never been to debut well that's why
sf is so funny like look at these
buildings look at this water look at
this cool town and uh portland maine
cool town asheville north carolina
portland maine pirates town bro very
piratey pirates town right there
portland maine is what portland oregon
is trying to be
and i i i still love portland oregon i
enjoy it there yeah i think the helium
in portland's [ __ ] fantastic i just
got back electric yeah i just recorded
and i did an album slash unofficial
special there in august like it's a but
it's still cause like people like
portland's so woke i'm like yeah but the
people who go to that club are not are
like [ __ ] make me laugh i don't give
a [ __ ] they're aware of the wokeness and
they go over the edge they
overcompensate but yes when you see a
dude with a beard and like a owl tattoo
and pulling an organ you like all right
man that's i get it you're that's a look
you went for you see that same look in
portland maine you're like this guy
spent 18 months at on a fishing board
fishing barge yes exactly he's tattooed
an owl because it was his only friend
and landed on the mast every day and
david news of the mainland and he named
the owl after his dead wife
they go all in francis yeah
portland maine gorgeous man gorgeous
[ __ ] summer
old dude beautiful
okay here you go here you go okay let's
do this most underrated city in america
damn
i got mine already [ __ ] locked up
pittsburgh
really yeah i like pittsburgh yeah i'm
going there the warhol museum is pretty
cool they got some cool stuff it's a
[ __ ] cool it doesn't like i don't
love the pittsburgh improv just throwing
that out there neither it's in a weird
area yeah it's like you you see the
abandoned royal attraction like we get
it you're struggling yeah yeah that's
right yeah but they have a
they have a [ __ ] awesome little club
called the club cafe where they go
that's a good room and comedy
sweet as hell but pittsburgh you walk
around like the the fun areas you're
like holy [ __ ] this is kind of beautiful
i know and like and then you walk around
downtown like it's all it's all
condensed to that like
little point yes and all the stadiums
are right there and the baseball stadium
about it's all very like and that river
is cool they shot batman there they did
they yeah yeah they got the gondola
going down the gondola yeah it's a cool
town well you got to remember these
these towns were huge with the steel
boom yeah they just blew up and had all
this money and income and then they just
uh slowly [ __ ] the best
underrated city i'm having a hard time
because i'm like i'm thinking like what
cities i like and i'm like are they
properly rated that's the thing i'm
thinking like okay i'll give you one i
like
wilmington north carolina oh fantastic
i'm going there this weekend it's a cool
city this is a setup no okay this feels
like a setup to be like sean have you
ever been to wilmington well thanks
byron
yes
i'm going there this weekend
sean do you like eating
do you like the gym just every setup
yeah dude i uh you know it's great
really quick you know what's [ __ ]
great about that show one time eric
andre was on and he had to be like so
eric you have crazy dreams like all of
this stuff
for everyone
for like a john roy who i i love it's
like so john you drive a lot you know
john's got a bit about being in a car
but like eric you're like so eric you
once thought you were a walrus
so eric you have a beef with uh the big
buford or whatever oh no the baconator
with the bacon here yeah
i gotta try he yelled at me in the
bathroom by right now
i talked about this once and he tried to
sue me so what sport aboard
yeah yeah bad idea oh yeah what the [ __ ]
are you doing what do you call this
supposed to be a great guy what are you
doing he's a nice guy but i don't know
we're making fun of comics unleashed
[ __ ] i want to do i want to do a that
should be a game where you're like you
do buy an island you don't do the name
but you just do the setup
just and you guess what the comedian is
like
so your dad's uh your dad was an al
qaeda
well you know the norm thing dinah what
no
yeah he goes i love dana
he just said like he was on uh comics
unleash he's like it couldn't have been
more leashed
he has a whole story about it but it's
it's great it just breaks the whole
thing down wait dina does have a joke
about her no she's got a joke about
keeping her dad out the country yeah
yeah yeah i don't want to [ __ ]
misconstrue or mess up another dad is
not an al-qaeda he's not yes
i didn't mean that
just a joke you [ __ ] all kind of works
[Laughter]
boom
dude uh
what's your city mark oh wilmington's
great it's almost like a mini new
orleans wilmington's awesome boozy
college town i'm thinking of like a city
that like great coach isn't talked about
like there's a lot of cities i love but
i feel like wilmington is like yeah
asheville does get a lot of praise
actually it's a lot of i love ash but
asheville's not underrated i just did
duncan trussell's podcast great guy he's
an astronaut i think
he's in asheville
[Music]
he's a very cool dude i i like duncan a
lot yeah i don't i'm trying to think of
other cities that don't get the shine
gainesville florida is a cool town
really yeah really cool town
now but would you go to college there
well i mean sure because that's where
the university of
florida is it's a college town right
okay it's cool
uh
[Music]
what's that place uh i got my second one
lined up when you're ready hit me
where's nasa in alabama oh punchville
huntsville is cool i hear hundreds of
times and all the nasa people move there
so you got the hillbilly and the nerds
kind of coming together you got you got
[ __ ] like
dip in the lip yeah like like that that
like dirty sort of frayed hat yeah and
like the boots and then they have a
[ __ ] british accent yes because
they're they've been there for 10 years
but they're from like southampton
england cultures columbia like are you a
british dipper
i thought that was a i thought you had
to be american it does sound like a
british tournament this guy's a [ __ ]
dipper
you should dip it in yeah what's the
other city eau claire wisconsin wow
never heard of it
so yeah there's a room there's a like a
they don't have a club but they've got
like a comedy production crew called
clearwater comedy which i learned eau
claire means
translates into clear water from french
so
but uh just just for you [ __ ]
francophiles out there oh claire e-a-u
eau claire not yeah not not just oh
claire
yeah
i got a you know i got another one
actually what san diego i was gonna say
santa barbara san diego is great
it's amazing great town that's a great
it's a fun it it san diego doesn't get a
lot of shine because it's got la in the
bay yes
like you put san diego in another in
another state it's their it's their a
city it's a military town here we go san
diego is like the clay thomas
clay thompson tom there you go we're i'm
[ __ ] he's coming dropping the ball
here
as if they were on another like wait
does that reference that analogy makes
sense as if klay thompson was on another
team oh yeah but also but i'm such a
hoops junkie that i'm kind of like
yeah you see the patrick ewing thing
yeah i'm just a hoops junkie that like i
think he gets more points for being on a
winner like for being like he to me like
like kevin mchale on the celtics or like
you know uh chris bosh on the heat like
you to me get more points for just
winning and yeah sure and he i mean he's
just i think he's the second best
shooter of all time and behind steph not
stephen is his teammate yeah
steph is uh i mean clay is [ __ ] cool
if you follow i follow him on instagram
and he's hilarious like he's he'll just
be driving with his bulldog and just be
chill like he's just a cool [ __ ] dude
yeah and he's always dressed as will
ferrell from semi-pro like he's just
like a fun dude
that's [ __ ] fun i'll say louisville
oh we're doing cities too
it's good good club that's renan's
hometown your best friend yeah i love
rhonda yeah
george clooney diane sawyer and muhammad
ali whoa
pretty good alumni and uh my morning
jacket is that right they're all from
that's their that's their that's where
they hail from there you go and the
slugger itself
the louisville slugger i know oh i went
to the factory and bought one when i
don't have any baseball guys just like i
want to get a bat i don't need to back
up i played hilarities and they give you
a bat every time
i [ __ ] love that club that's that's a
club in my top five sell out they give
you a bat with your name engraved that's
why i've only gotten
that's why i've only gotten a glove well
they gave me one i brought at the
airport and they go what are you doing
with this they mailed it oh that's the
move so i know some guy in the cleveland
airport got my bat wait you tried to
check it yeah i tried to get it through
security oh dude dude i if you have a
well i guess i i i had a shilleley
that i [ __ ] what's that it's an irish
oh [ __ ] whooping stick sounds like a
black chick it's chilly
right
[Laughter]
so i got to catch up to you guys well
i'm trying to milk this one because i
know if i have another i'm going to be
uh snuggling up to this gym shall we
all right [ __ ] it
what um
we got to do some christmas stuff too
because oh [ __ ] you guys have any
because you got i'm the jew here do you
guys have any christmas traditions
i mean like what are you guys doing for
christmas this year oh and is there any
long-standing stuff oh i want to know i
bought a tree today wow i got a mini
tree
and uh that's just a good feeling you
put that [ __ ] over your back you smell
that tree sap [ __ ] they brought it
home the cat's playing with it you know
it's hitting all the branches
it's exciting we have more ice matt oh
sorry matt your producer good producer
really seems to care yeah uh but no real
tradition we had a fake tree growing up
but it always bothered me
the fake tree yeah the fake trees are
nicer because you just break them out
every year but i get it it is there's
something about walking past the trees
in new york city
you're like that's even as a jew i'm
like oh it's so forbidden yeah
like a palestinian woman right you're
not gonna get that with the dreidels
there's no sniff oh
wait but were you
did y'all did you not
practice christmas or like did you have
a tree in the house no no no no no my
parents are jewish we my biological dad
has a tree so we i've set up a tree at
his place a couple times um
but we're not close i mean but you know
uh he's jewish also but his wife is uh
is is catholic
so but you know we never uh but jews
appreciate christmas more than i'd say
because it's uh
i feel like we're mets fans and the
christians are like the yankees fans so
you guys have the big thing and we're
just like good for you right right yeah
that's like how rappers rap about money
but you don't really see a lot of white
people about money thank you they're
gonna have the best gotham studios baby
matt peters there's no one better no one
better i just want to toss this out here
what do we look uh
time wise oh jesus christ yeah he's
coming by
yeah yeah flown by this these manhattans
man they'll get you yeah
good cocktail really what are we at
matthew we gotta be at at least an hour
and ten
oh we just hit an hour oh all right all
right all right we need to do it we
could do a small one each yeah
[Music]
yeah i tell jokes
there we go
we're getting old
fellas plug it i could i could this is a
bar called the i the ir aaron's irish
rose
in new orleans yep so they were both
from yep irish coffees
oh that are you allowed to tell where
you're doing your special yeah what's up
when's your next special so you taped
one already in portland you're taping
another you because you've backlogged so
much you have so much great material you
have hours of materials
because you've never put out a special
since your half hour right you do the
albums
where's how i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up
because i came i was the tail end of
that generation that was like
you know keep your [ __ ]
and get it put get it on a major network
get it on a thing get it on hbo get on
netflix
get on a netflix you know coming centers
get it on something don't put it out
there for free i was the tailor of that
generation
so i was very precious about everything
we were there too
but y'all were smart about it y'all
started putting out like i i still have
trouble embracing the social media
monster like that's very hard it's a
nightmare but y'all are both excellent
at it and i [ __ ] up and
get resentful of my myself daily and
just like goddamn i need to put more
stuff out there because i really don't
have [ __ ] out there
i just don't have [ __ ] out there didn't
go and i'm putting out more and more yes
so
i you got a ton well yeah and you have
so much great material man you really
you really are like one of those dudes
your last album you had that story about
the strip club which is like scuttlebutt
the names
that's great great bit thank you you
were really i think like elite when i i
think as far as storytellers it's like
you jim jeffries cosby and uh
no but you guys are really like you were
really amazing storyteller thank you but
you've got two this is not happenings
right
three three and they're all
multi-million views you gotta check look
up his stories online i mean sean is
such a captivating storyteller
because there's so many jokes there's
always a great payoff yes and they have
heart they have emotions they have heart
the one you're in love with someone in
one of them yeah i mean yeah that i mean
that's numerous
but i did so i got i have a new album
dropping on christmas eve whoa
it's called king scorpio
uh on the helium network nice uh it's
dropping on christmas eve but we filmed
that recording
at helium in portland and cut together
like an unofficial special that's going
to come out in january oh boy i'm on
youtube hell yeah thank you because
that's that's where it's at all right
well that will be in like 10 days from
now yeah so that that album drops on
christmas eve king scorpio check it out
i'm filming i haven't heard it but i
know it's going to be great because it's
sean
truly one of the best comics so please
look him up really really a great stand
up but but i'm filming the first
official special at tippetinas in new
orleans on february 3rd
february 3rd 2022.
thank you for the drink by the way
tippeteen is in new orleans is our
babysitter like our cbgb's or something
it's like yeah hometown
been there for a million years it's a
local divy music i love it because it's
owned by the band that became famous
there
galactic
they own it galactic so they became they
came up there and then when it went on
sale they were like hey and they bought
it
so i think that's [ __ ] beautiful but
i remember going going to look at venues
back in june tip of teams was the first
one we went to look at and in my head i
was like man this is like 800 seats it's
just gonna be way too big and when i
walked in i was like oh it's just huge
in my memory yes and it's how many seats
is it i mean it's seating it's only 200.
wow but standing they can get like a
thousand yeah yeah but like standing
room but so we're not going to do so
we're doing standing room specials no
but like yeah it's a it's an amazing
venue and yeah i know i've been there
it's [ __ ] awesome february 3rd 2022
tickets are already on sale there's two
shows two tapings
seven and nine oh that's gonna be great
yeah i did the hallowed wolf last
weekend that place is great it's great
first place ever got paid due comedy so
it's fun to go back and sell it out but
the guy gave me a bag of merch and i was
like what's this
stew stew and he goes i was like what's
this for he goes well everywhere you go
you wear a tippatina [ __ ] can you rep
oh yeah sorry oh [ __ ] is there music
venues i'll give you they sent me a
bunch of have you got me did you do
you sure you just did it just did it
that's a great venue great look at that
he's great yeah we had a great show my
parents came kind of ruined everything
wow they don't normally come no no it
was brutal
he was in my head the whole time
curse words oh dude i did i was at
gramercy and my folks are uh they showed
up well my parents came and they're
they're like double masked they're like
terrified of everyone i'm like
you don't have to come i feel bad you're
here yeah you're like no we want to be
here they're like we've got them like a
separate row they're like in the corner
i'm like all right that's what i did i
got a vip in the back and then somebody
i do a q a at the end and somebody goes
is your mom here as a joke and i went
yeah she's actually in the back and she
stood up and did this whole thing they
got a big laugh got a huge pop yeah i
mean people love that yeah they love it
they love it i didn't i didn't do that
thank god my dad was like what the [ __ ]
i'm here yeah it's so funny when when
sometimes people do q and a's and it's
like all right and then it's like uh
oh no one has any questions i know that
has happened
well i usually would just say give me
current events because i feel weird
being like q a i'm like [ __ ] who the
[ __ ] am i yes but like you know uh
yeah i mean that's that's epic your
hometown your hometown hero man you're
do you do your thing no you are you you
you've your shit's so good i i i know
it's going to pop off this and you'll
get a clip it's so is it different
material yeah well it's a different like
it's just that like the what i recorded
and the thing that the album that's
coming out on the the
helium uh the healing geez i'm [ __ ]
my hammer no these are the album that's
coming out on christmas eve helium yes
that's like material the thing i'm doing
on uh the third at typitina's it's it's
based off of the one-person show i did
in edinburgh like four years ago
that i shelved when i got when i came
back from edinburgh 2017 i shelfed the
show because it was a lot
and it's it's f it's a comedy but
there's like emotional parts of it but
it's a comedy but i shelved it because i
couldn't really do it at clubs and i had
a bunch of clubs lined up right and then
just time passed and all of a sudden i
was working on this new this other hour
and then i recorded that for now for
scuttlebutt so prolific and then well
what so where can people find it is it
just an album or is it going to be on
youtube as well or whatever the album is
going to be uh you can find helium
records but anywhere albums are got it's
called
scorpio
yeah scorpio king scorpio and then it'll
we're going to release it on january
24th on youtube
december 24th oh no uh january okay so
we're doing we're doing the album
release for on christmas eve and then
the special release
on 24th but it's unofficial and then
the actual
[ __ ]
i don't think it's up yet but why why
are you under unannounced
should we be plugging the [ __ ] out of
this thing
oh uh it's because we don't know exactly
where we're
[ __ ] putting it yet
we know we're putting on youtube but i
think it's going to be helium's youtube
oh okay yeah we don't know yet but like
but but the but the special i'm filming
at tippatinas
we have we i do not know where that's
ending up yet but i know 800 pound
gorilla's producing it all right and
we're uh in in conjunction with uh all
things comedy i believe oh well like we
don't we just don't know like it's like
that's we're gonna film it and then be
like all right where's it going but all
right these days it's just about getting
someone to do it with you yeah i mean
you [ __ ] both know i did 800 pound
without to lunch
yeah so there you go yeah they're they
they're great they do good work and they
let you have the spotlight they give it
all to you yeah yeah
yeah
and i mean you i mean
i mean your sam's probably got two more
specials in a documentary in the pipes
you
and your own like look how drunk you are
i mean this is the pot calling the cops
on the couch but like
with you well no i mean you know i
should have said we're let's do let's do
uh you had so much gimlets
well you got so much uh
you have so much backlog man it's
exciting i think it's going to be huge
for you it's about time
you're like an artist you're all over
the world you're doing your edinburgh
[ __ ] in portland and all the it's great
i mean yeah thank you it's just i think
it's gonna be a big year for you it's
just about you this is something that
thank you but this is something that
going back to what you all were saying
earlier or you were saying earlier
specifically it's like there are less
gatekeepers and that is great
yeah but it also means that like there's
a whole other wing added on
to
being a comedian now that is was
difficult to adjust to here's what it is
we used to be boxers you know you look
at his boxing sonny liston and muhammad
ali and all these guys the sugar ray and
then now we have to be mma fighters you
can't just have bot you gotta have a
wrestling and a grapple and uh yeah all
this other [ __ ] basically basically
we're businessmen now yes
you gotta have twitter you have to have
a video you have to have a sketch you
have to have a podcast you have to have
a stand-up set but it's good
it is good that we take back some of
that control because i do agree but
their taste is lacking the industry is
always going to suck but you know us
doing our [ __ ] having a link to have
people sent to when you when you're
when your friends promote you and your
and you j and you're like here's the
link it's so much better than watch at 9
00 p.m
you know no one [ __ ] does that true
that's true it's like homework it's it's
good and bad pros and cons bittersweet
yeah because would you want to you ever
heard of the old buddhist quote no i'm
shit-faced do i hear that old buddhist
quote where they say if you
all the people all of the human race got
together in one place and we all threw
our problems in a pit
you'd pull yours back first
you know like saying like
you got a crick in your neck
i'm uh oh
whatever it is we all have our own [ __ ]
but i don't want to be fat so i pull
that back because i want my [ __ ] i'd
rather be impotent because you at least
know how to deal with your [ __ ] yes
exactly exactly it's the same with the
industry it's like yeah the industry
sucks now you got to do your own [ __ ]
you got to you got to post videos
but
this is still better than just the
industry yeah certainly that makes sense
everything's
everything's weight everything's way
better than
it was honestly i mean they they're so
bad i mean it also sucks how much power
netflix has
you know because
look hbo is cool but also like no one's
popping off hbo specials either so it's
kind of like youtube right like that
isn't that weird it was the watermark i
still look at it as the watermark in
some ways or just like the personal like
oh hbo but you know
now it's purple it's real well it's
really like netflix and then youtube
which is weird you know well it's
because they're the only two global
streaming oh
they're the only two that are global
like like vimeo where are you at you're
[ __ ] dropping the ball here what are
you doing vim you could swing in here
and have some [ __ ] i just think
youtube is hard it's it's this giant
they're owned by google i mean [ __ ]
the w hotel good and just dick suck like
wait what yeah
what are we missing on wait so
i just for some reason when you said you
were hammered one of my favorite mark
norman hammered stories
is uh i mean there's numerous i'm gonna
tell i'm gonna tell i'm gonna give a pg
version
but we were at we were at whiplash oh
yeah which old ucb show ucb show monday
nights 11 p.m was [ __ ] fantastic
and
you leave whiplash and the play was go
up the block to the molly wii yes and
there was one night where like
the whole group of comics would all come
up and the vibe was the show was kind of
weird that night and everybody's sort of
like i don't know but we'd all been
drinking because there was booze at this
cloud i don't know i don't think i want
to go to my way and mark's just like no
[ __ ] that come on come on we're in new
york we're doing comedy come on
we're going to we're going to miley week
come on he does his mark things like ah
come on what are you going to go go home
what are you where are you going to go
go home where you going to take the
train for it now come on come on we're
all going and like there's a whole group
of us there's like eight of us like yeah
yeah yeah the reality is i live we're
going 18 hours into brooklyn and i
didn't want to go home well no that was
the funny part we're all like yeah we're
going to mali we're all like [ __ ]
charged like a [ __ ] and we're walking
them out of the way and i look back and
i see mark running towards the a the
opposite direction like you got us all
[ __ ] riled up
and like yeah we're going and no one
looked at you and you just as soon as we
all start going you're like
it's scottish goodbye
everybody riled up and you go
i always said there's the irish goodbye
and then when you go when an irish
goodbye and then when you realize you
left your phone and have to go back
like you didn't irish goodbye that's the
scottish hello
[Laughter]
mike cat or it might be josh gondolman
somebody has that great joke that that's
the irish goodbye the jewish goodbye is
we have to say bye to everyone nine
times and then leave
yeah i might have butchered that that's
funny though yeah what are there any um
should we do holiday movies oh yeah
christmas app right can we do a bit
should we do a peeve do you have a peeve
i i worry about i got tons of [ __ ]
pieces hit us with a pee my newest okay
so an old uh long-standing peeve
i don't think this one's
next week
wow
all right i mean i don't know we could
do them that too i don't give a [ __ ] i
mean after christmas vacation i feel
like it's a drop-off it's a drop-off
christmas story
love actually christmas story i mean die
hard i still go die oh die you think
it's the christmas movie it's a die hard
christmas guy we get it that's right
it's a christmas movie that's santa i
mean it's an actual back that sounds
great it's a great one
what else anything else
i mean i really i've never seen it's a
wonderful life what
i've never i've never actually seen
a scrooge is fun scrooge is actually
probably one of an underrated because
bill murray gives that like
and you could do like that speech that
bill murray speech at the end
so good yeah i mean i grew up with that
movie i'm actually yeah i'm gonna throw
scrooge in there all right yeah
no peeve that thought i was young i
don't even remember it to be honest it's
dark
bobcats in it i mean dude groundhog day
is dark all the [ __ ] is kind of weirdly
dark by today's standards it's a new
play on a christmas carol the ghost
christmas pass all that [ __ ] yeah it's
actually it's pretty [ __ ] great
i was just hanging out with bobcat in
chicago he's an awesome he's an awesome
dude and still and still got it he went
on and his movie with dana gould his new
movie uh check it out it's on it's
anywhere you buy that stuff it's great
oh yeah
i'll check that out i like oh the
documentary guys yeah certainly dana's
the best i love it funny as hell and
funny off the cuff as well as
one of the best comedy minds i mean just
so so good simpsons for years yeah
one of his episodes just got censored
because there's a tiananmen square joke
there's like cnn story
it's all over the news it got sent
really they won't play it in china
because there's a tiananmen square joke
by the way dana's adopted like multiple
chinese girls yeah right so i was like
maybe this isn't like china phobic
that's that's what i hate we never take
in the good as much as we take in the
bad you know if you said this horrible
thing but you also do this great thing
we just focus on the horrible thing you
said so what about the great thing i did
it's also a joke yeah it's also a joke
on a comedy show on a cartoon
i mean the truth is like they just
people just want
i believe that there is a dopamine
release that happens when you are angry
or defended
and for years
it just wasn't a massive experience like
it is now now it's on and i feel like
there's a there's a younger generation
or even an older generation i don't
think it's generational i think it's
just like yeah she's the type of person
who enjoys being like oh no no no
not even listening there's a i can't
believe there's a person who like enjoys
that like
moment and like
[ __ ] it makes them feel good yeah
they're not going to win because we
don't no one's getting censored well
they could do it alone in their room but
they don't they have to broadcast it
which shows that right it's for some
other reason but i mean like
there's this whole [ __ ] i can't
remember where i read this guy i'm drunk
but like
censorship isn't really happening it's
not real
like
censorship means we say something a
[ __ ] government authority comes in
that door and arrest all three of us for
speaking our minds lenny bruce was
censored exactly like but being kicked
off of like a platform or someone not
wanting to hear what you have to say
that's not censorship that's like
whenever alex jones or those [ __ ] go
off on like the censorship they're like
no one's no one just we just no one
cares you have to [ __ ] say well the
closest that's not sensitive we get to
that is with china [ __ ] like i feel like
a lot of like lebron or whatever be like
this and that and this and that and goes
yeah yeah and then you go what about
china and he goes all right we gotta get
out of here like well that feels a
little sensory well once you're in the
building around uh oh you mean like you
can't [ __ ] with the money
but that's still not censorship that's
the team that's self-editing but it
feels like why is he so worried about
this and not worried about that well
that's probably because he's got
investments for sure i don't know nba in
china and the truth is any billionaire
in terms of being an activist has a huge
achilles heel let's be real you cut
corners to make that kind of money but
china has slavery and all this [ __ ] and
everybody's like hey what are you gonna
do it's china
but hey we gotta stop doing this
lebron's also done a lot of incredible
activism i agree
yeah i mean look
every billionaire has got uh their [ __ ]
right no no one's possible no no one's
everyone's got [ __ ] we act like if
you're not perfect we're gonna ruin your
life i mean bezos has done a ton of
terrible [ __ ] he's also given a ton of
money i mean yes you know it's he gave
me two bill
he didn't but but that's where i reveal
i'm a billionaire now
he sent you to space yeah
that that what nasa is really dropping
the [ __ ] ball and the opportunity to
straight up like uh extort some money
from these billionaires they take them
to space and they're like this is
amazing well we're not going back
[Laughter]
branson you want to get back
we're gonna need about tree bill to get
you [ __ ] back on the planet
if not enjoy to see a tranquility and
consider yourself merman yeah you want
to end world hunger yeah here we go yeah
yeah yeah nasty you could really be
[ __ ] saving the day here
take a you take one trip around the moon
come back with 200 [ __ ] bill yeah
looks like i said 200 bro why do i turn
a [ __ ]
dot like a like a cab driver a straight
up 400 like a union delegate
400 mil i had my head in manhattan but i
sound like i'm from [ __ ] staten
island
well kim kardashian just saved a bunch
of kids from afghanistan so there she
goes there's your money uh well spent i
just i just looked at i was like why is
that why am i do i have headphones on oh
that's matt peters the producer
this [ __ ] these men hands go down too
easy
david lynch film right i will say myself
for a minute
there's something about
whiskey cocktails in the winter that
just hit different ways
you say that five times fast
whiskey cocktails something about
whiskey cocktails in the winter
it's not that hard wishy cocktails in
the winter is it yeah you're like mother
goose all of a sudden
winter whitski cocktails in the winter
if he's mother goose who are you father
duck
[Laughter]
this one is we're uh we might be a
little drunk on this episode you put
[ __ ] cbd in here
manhattan's in the winter man it's
[ __ ]
can't beat it man it's glad i drove it
could you get the uh
well you get the ice so you kind of
chill but it's like the warmth of the
whiskey
it hits everything can i sleep here
after this i might need to nap it up can
we order some of that chinese food from
downstairs oh
now you're talking i want some of that
scrambled eggs and shrimp oh i want to
say one thing about uh you talk about
the table like hey get this table out of
here yeah rory scoville
one of the funniest guys of course oh
dude jedi brilliant jedi
he was i this is a old wives tale a
legend that this this uh went all over
the country talking about you talking
about in vancouver
seattle
okay which okay seattle comedy fest
which is a big deal everybody's nervous
oh god you want to win you want to do
well you don't get kicked out
he went on stage at some theater he's
like in the finals of seattle comedy
fest a man and a woman get up during
their during his set and walks to the
bathroom or leaves or something and he
was like that was weird did i say
something and he goes you know what [ __ ]
it
let's he goes in the crowd brings their
table on the stage and brings their two
chairs up on stage they come back from
the bathroom and they're like what what
and he goes oh this is your seats they
come up on stage and he starts riffing
with them and it's killing and then it's
just ripping with a couple rory scoville
needs a camera at every show because i
feel like magic will happen genius
that's the other story about him having
a cordless mic and he's walking around
the stage like [ __ ] with everything
in the room he was just so good off the
cuff and he sees an elevator like an old
freight elevator but it's glass
so he gets in the elevator and he's
riffing
in the elevator while going up so they
can all see him go up he's got the
cordless bike i mean he's just like on
another level that guy yeah man rory's
[ __ ] great he really is funny where's
he where you been i remember mobile i
remember where the [ __ ] you been buddy
harlow and esme back in the day yeah
i remember that show it was a brett
favre this is how long ago was brett
favre was i think on the packers so this
how long this is going to date the story
but
they're playing and he just starts the
game is on the back and he just starts
narrating it
he starts calling the game and it's
killing like he's just doing and that
announcer calling brett favre and the
crowd it's like an ulti room they're
[ __ ] dying
that's how you do it man and then we got
to follow that with uh so what what's up
with the post office dating's weird yeah
he's just
he's
he's touched he's like enlightened his
comedy way we're like i wish you could
harness it incredible improvisation yeah
you gotta be in the room for him put
that guy in any moment any moment he's
always in the moment 911 on the tower he
was killing even like
even in just person he's just like yeah
chatting with him he's just he's there
he's in the moment yeah he's just
important to be in the moment yeah i
know he's like talking about things on
like he's like what'd you get and you
just tell him what you order and he just
responds and you're like i never i never
looked at shrimp that way but yeah
and it's not like he's gonna where you
from there's none of that [ __ ] it's all
next level just
in the moment [ __ ] yeah that's why it
put him in top glass like just give them
a show where they just don't even give
it a theme it's just like it's todd and
rory yeah and let them just just follow
them into places i saw them once ty
glass was on stage at whiplash this is
nine years ago and uh he's bombing and
rory goes we get it you're gay
yeah i was hosting oh really yeah and
then ty glass like you tell that killed
and it bothered him and he goes uh oh
yeah well that's why your dad's dead
is dead and i mean they just went back
and forth just saying the worst [ __ ] and
they're best friends yeah but uh it was
it was pretty pretty epic
but that's when you get in the basement
at 2 a.m we have a new [ __ ] mark here
yeah
i love it i'm into the belgian you don't
like it no i love it i'm into it i've
been due to belch
[Music]
you had one on deck you had one in the
pipes i know how'd you pull that off i
don't know
that sucked that was terrible so sam
i started puking all over the night
oh man my girlfriend's been farting what
do you think about that
i'm working on a new bit about how my
girlfriend was someone troll should i i
need an ending in this but i'll say sure
sometimes she'll leave the room too far
but she never does that with her
feelings
you know like
like uh like
and and i was like well you know it's
weird as i prefer the uh the farts yes
like a woman i've never had a woman fart
in the bathroom at two in the morning
i've been like guess i gotta go in there
that's the turn i have right now i don't
know i don't know what the
i might need a fart will dissipate the
feeling you gotta you gotta face them
when you said your girlfriend's been
farting lately
well i guess we've been together long
enough where she's like
yeah i know i mean there's there's a
comment that's just lately though no but
i think i think there's a guard down
that is set with yeah yeah i think women
are weird about doing that and then once
and i'm kind of like i don't give a [ __ ]
i go what are you what are you holding
in for i always
i dude i always i always fart early
you know i fart early too i do i sit
down i go i have a bit i haven't i would
like i would like you know i i did a
thing where i would light a fart in
front of a girl every time just
because it's very doable i don't know i
if i had to fart right now i'd like give
me a lighter but i don't really that's a
southern mating call yeah would you do
that and just and see how they react and
you know if you're going to be
either longer than that night yeah yeah
dude farting i mean i just don't want it
look this is how i look at it she's
allowed to fart she's a human being it's
a bodily function but you don't want
your woman farting every 10 seconds and
you don't want your man crying every 10
seconds well is it there's
crying for a man they're the same
i don't know i'm just saying look it's
okay for a guy to cry your relative dies
or whatever you especially don't want
her crying or him crying because she
farted
right right you don't want them
happening at the same time or her
farting actually but it's okay because i
know it's because you're crying
i know i get up [ __ ]
i know when she i i the thing is like at
least you know the thing is you don't
know when a guy's gonna cry
you know when a woman's gonna fart we
ordered we ordered indian ah it's coming
you know it's the funeral i feel like
i guess certain events yes it's going
out to indian buffet going to a funeral
those are the two guarantees
she's gonna fart i'm gonna cry
but
it sucks i mean i mean terrible to go to
an indian funeral then
i said you're just and also you don't
want to hold either one in
you hold it apart you're holding a cry
something bigger is going to come out
later
wow you're going to [ __ ] the bed you're
getting a lot
in many different ways yes yes exactly
both literally and figuratively yes
which by the way can we switch
can we make figuratively the word
instead of i literally am on fire right
now
just say figuratively that's true it's
what you
actually it's literally one extra
syllable you're right like what people
are just like like
i could literally eat a horse like nah i
could i figuratively eat a horse i get
it yeah i i l or even when you're using
it correctly it's like do you know any
other [ __ ] adjectives well it's like
every other one we got to go to the peak
you know you go he's a nazi and you're
like he's jewish what
you're the biggest one he's a rape he's
a whatever he's a pedophile you go to
them he's a nazi he's a jew yeah
yeah guys louis is hispanic
giving a little friendly little friendly
knock on the shoulder there you go
he's having a good run plug other what
you got dates you want to plug on the
road late december january february
whatever you get i literally have
did we get that peeve
oh the peeve
real quick what's the pivot yeah hit it
with the people uh the peeve is so
this is not a new one of people who do
not
uh who play music without headphones on
public transformations oh that's crazy
like i get it okay i get it without a
good music with cyclists i get it
okay that's a big zipping buy well also
because you can't have headphones on
when you're riding a bike you have to be
able to hear cars and [ __ ] yeah i never
thought of that and yeah yeah i get it
but on [ __ ] it's it's just like i get it
you're a [ __ ] you're on a subway you
don't give a [ __ ] it's that attitude i
think it's mainly like i don't give a
[ __ ] i play mom [ __ ] music you can't
tell me you can't tell me what to listen
to [ __ ] all y'all yeah fine it's always
the same music too can we get just once
i want to hear james taylor on those
speakers that would be great the one
that but the peeve is now and this is
only in new york i don't know because i
don't ride public transportations all
the time in other cities but people
watching [ __ ] tv without headphones
on on their phones crazy crazy what are
you out of damn track bus the
bus it's crazy it's an epidemic like i
don't like it you know what and i think
you're not in the bowl bus anymore well
in my day that was a lot of casino games
come on so my my answer is like if
you're if someone i like i'ma start
[ __ ] you're gonna sit there and watch
your [ __ ] la it's also like i get it
the music can kind of make you seem cool
if you're like i'm going to play this
[ __ ] death metal i'm going to play
some mastodon at full volume and i don't
give a [ __ ] with anybody thanks fine
that can kind of seem you make maybe my
people might be like [ __ ] that guy but
he's kind of scary but when you're
sitting there watching
season one of ozark
with no headphones it's like what's your
what's the end game there you're trying
i think it's because they're like oh i'm
just now catching up on this so people
think i have a life and i'm busy all
right right like i like laura lenny too
but there's a time and a place right
right and that time is [ __ ] home
[ __ ] home or get some air or get
some guck [ __ ] like because that
makes me want to sit next to you and be
like i'm going to watch the next episode
best moment in my life i'm going to
listen to the episode you're watching
and play the next one best one
i used to go to the rec center it's a
bunch of poor people and old people in
me and there was always this puerto
rican guy who played loud music all day
long
salsa [ __ ] whatever everybody hated him
but he was old and weird so we all let
it slide one day this young black guy
comes in he starts blaring hip hop and
they both look each other like what are
you doing and he was like what are you
doing he's like what are you doing and i
was sitting there curling going
[ __ ] you both you're both [ __ ] and
now you're mad at that [ __ ] for being
you and you're that [ __ ] and it was
like it was abusive you look kind of
like a batman villain when you laugh
that way in that jacket yeah no dude
the curler
i'm the curler
yeah but it was just it was a beautiful
moment seeing these two inconsiderate
[ __ ]
yeah and they still didn't get it they
were still like why are you playing i've
been playing my music but i'm playing my
music well welcome to life we're living
in a society yeah we all kind of have to
get along here and just like let [ __ ]
[ __ ] but yeah headphones or just that
would be the thing too if i if i had the
money to do it just have like a supply
of very nice headphones some beats
i just walk over and be like there you
go man yes you're set there's no reason
anymore considering i just gave you 400
headphones yeah uh that released with
acromenon
i saw a guy
this girl was listening to rap music
really loud and this guy went up to it
he's like what are you doing like we're
all trying to like enjoy ourselves i'm
reading she's old like what are we doing
here
and she was like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
he's like why are you mad at me you're
the one being loud she's like i can do
whatever i want that's what it is it's i
can do whatever i want that's what it is
like you can but do you want to be an
actor you're not a good person yeah
that's you're allowed to do anything oh
sure you know right and if you went up
to her with a microphone why are you a
good person they go of course i'm a
great person that's the problem they
don't know that they're doing [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
and that's that's yeah well that person
is never gonna find someone who treats
them well
like if you're if you're the type of
person that
blasts music on the subway like you're
not putting out your best foot forward
on the first date right you're gonna be
with a guy who treats you like absolute
dog [ __ ] yeah or woman
and uh he's gonna play music loud
without headphones while he's treating
you like [ __ ] yeah the next morning he
blasted
the [ __ ] out
yeah
yeah
yeah that's yeah
you get on the [ __ ] train and you're
listening to someone like man what if
i'm what if i'm not caught up yet on the
unbreakable kimmy schmidt
i wish it was that show i wish they were
just once they were watching el kemper
yeah it's always like vikings or some
[ __ ] yeah yeah which is a good show
maybe the best intro of any show ever
i've never seen it you never seen the
unbreakable kimmy dude
no oh yeah that's a great intro mike
britt is in the intro pull it up matt
do you just get the intro of it you're
gonna [ __ ] love it so the premise of
the show is so dark the premise is
basically these are women who are kept
under underground as captives and they
break out and now they're trying to live
a normal life but this guy kept them as
like slaves what that's dark it's dark
but look at the intro this is a tina let
them out get that get the sound out it's
a great show it's a legit great show
from start to finish i mean the intro is
so funny look at this [ __ ] whoa
yeah whoa and now they live in new york
that's my friend oh yeah yeah was he
down there
no
he's a neighbor oh okay
well the whole thing is like that
we might be drunk is sponsored by better
help what's standing in the way of
achieving your goals a lot
figure it out with better help uh you
know look i've i'm in therapy it's been
very very big for me i i love it uh he's
he's definitely helped oh yeah i just
talked to him yeah yeah great guy great
therapist better help is therapy for the
21st
century better help is professional
therapy all online it's all remote do it
from the comfort and privacy of your own
home flexible schedule phone or video
calls at your convenience get a good
match they will put you with a licensed
therapist who is right for you that's
the most important part of therapy you
need someone to feel like you can talk
to them who gets you it's fast when you
sign up you can start talking to your
therapist in less than 48 hours no
waiting around it's affordable you
didn't have to be rich to pay for this
it's uh and financial aid's available
this is great and now you can send
messages to your therapist anytime paul
what about bob bill murray great movie
great movie they'll get back to you in
between sessions don't like your person
if you want to switch therapists you can
do it anytime for free trust me it helps
to have someone outside your world to
talk to it's easy to schedule affordable
and will take a load of off your
shoulders over 100 over a million people
have taken charge of their mental health
join them tell them how to do it mark
better help has a special offer for our
listeners visit betterhelp.com
drunk for 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p dot com slash drunk for 10 off
your first month betterhelp.com slash
drunk sign up for better help to start
living a happier life today just try it
folks you don't like it don't keep going
nate pergotzi jerry seinfeld you're both
kooks get some therapy you chooch what
else you got
we're brought to you by sheath underwear
sheath i'm wearing it right now i think
hell yeah
nice that's it that's it hold on
up i'm wearing women's panties forget it
don't keep keep going
we love you
is the best keeps your balls off your
leg two pouches one for your dick and
one for your balls keep the ammo
separate from the gun supportive sexy
looking my girlfriend it's her favorite
underwear
how much i love mine it's crazy i love
it i love it i wear them constantly
you have your underwear that you look
forward to wearing yes and then you have
the others you're like swiss cheese
undies my balls are going to dip in the
toilet yeah i'm getting a mark uh shout
out to that classic geraldo bit
his balls dipped in the toilet oh yeah
the idea for sheath came from its
founder us army soldier robert padden
during the second torn iraq there's an
american hero guys yeah support this
awesome veteran-owned company whose
founder is a big big comedy fan tell
them how to do it mark yes i love sheet
i love robert get on there go to sheath
underwear dot com and order with promo
code drunk to get 20 off your first
order and sheath underwears 100 money
back guarantee that sheath underwear dot
com promo code drunk get sheet underwear
and let them support your
balls whoa i'm banned from heinous by
the way
were you funny
[Laughter]
[Music]
they emailed my agent and said if you
don't drop him we'll never book one of
your clients again
why
because the show started an hour late
and i made fun of the club when i was
like
ding dong hat [ __ ] is a ding dong fat
[ __ ]
that i mean that's that look that ain't
cutting edge good one there
i got
i got mad because they uh
they would do a [ __ ] shop before i
got on stage before the headliners
showed up they say they do it to pay the
[ __ ] feature i'm like hey dude the
show's packed wait can i remind you it's
a [ __ ] shot to everyone whose
birthday it is yeah so i gotta say i had
one night where it was 14 [ __ ]
birthdays
you gotta go on stage after 14 [ __ ]
shots 14.
yes oh my there's almost a [ __ ] hour
of
shots
45 minutes they're doing these with
their hands behind their back and uh and
then you're like i gotta follow this
[ __ ] i don't want to do this [ __ ]
and uh it's insane wow that is crazy
what is a bloke
but then i go on and shot a little tube
that you get
and i i think i went on there and i was
like you know half in the bag at that
point i'm just like there's like a guy's
dick remember
well there's like a little hyena in a
tuxedo i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
logo and it's killing me just [ __ ] on
the logo yeah and that's it the logo
[ __ ] i mean that's standard it's
standard so i get off stage and goes
this is a [ __ ] family business i'm
like the [ __ ] you're doing [ __ ]
shots before me and and i remember uh i
remember hillary was our age at the time
she called me she's like this is bad
this is really bad i'm like what i do i
don't know what i did i was a comedian
it's not bad you oh you don't do two
[ __ ] clubs he's never get three he's got
three where's the third one up his
[ __ ] ass yeah [ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] drinks you're working down guys
no i wouldn't do that he's a nice enough
guy but also [ __ ] the heinous clubs
they they bumped they bumped me from
both of them because
i was i was dirty and he was like you
got to be clean i'm like i have to be
clean again after doing bloating after
the [ __ ] shots all the blow job shots
you want me to be clean wow yeah i love
that
all right there's the [ __ ] shot no
uh it's uh it's a clean comedian socks
are
he sucks you like sucks
you always lose one in the dryer
where do you think they went huh
i bet all my socks are in tulum
[Laughter]
damn
the the [ __ ]
are you doing the addison improv that's
a good room i'm there yeah yeah
i just i mean i just got back from there
this when this comes out oh right right
i hope it's fun yeah i can't wait that's
a great room
it's in the middle it's kind of in the
outskirts of town but it's like a suburb
dallas is the outskirts of itself it's
huge you know what i'm saying such a
[ __ ] massive city that like but as
the yeah the addison improv is fun to
sell yeah i know right we gotta wrap
this up but straight up uh yeah improv
uh
nope that's not a yes me me
seanpatton.com got a shitload of dates
for the next two months prepared to be
in san francisco at the punch line it
looks like december 25th one night rooms
uh doing yeah doing acme for oh for new
year's that's right yeah yeah roland
asheville and uh
yeah i should all go see sean he's a
really really great comic yeah there's a
lot of one night vanna georgia i like
him i tried to i booked a bunch of
one-nighters because i like to try it i
want to go to wormhole that's a great
[ __ ] place i love savannah yeah
lincoln this place zhu bart old comedian
and then i got i got and then the comedy
club of kansas city have you heard about
this place yeah i played there it's good
i've heard it's pretty [ __ ] great
great great barbecue in this back to the
creek hey
it's about time
so long i went i was in april oh okay
and then uh and then there's like five
dates i haven't added yet but i'm also
going to be in houston now you mean
seattle also going to be in uh and the
special is february third that's when i
yeah i'm i'm i'm not putting up any
dates afterwards because i'm like no
just focus on this yes you know what i
mean
i'll put up my [ __ ] dates and i don't
have i don't have any i'm actually
taking march off this should they're
just to kind of like
not march the rest of february but [ __ ]
starts to get in march i'm not going to
post again until february but like
to get some new [ __ ] yeah just like
build to live well just build like two
shows two shows yeah nice who's filming
it oh 800 800 oh that'll be great eric
abrams directing
eric
love him
uh yeah it's gonna i'm [ __ ] excited
i'm ecstatic about it and uh d you know
come see these shows they're gonna be
fun nice wait man go see sean he's a
killer you're not gonna be disappointed
and it's about time you put some [ __ ] on
wax you got 18 million hours up in the
ether it's nice to see it coming down
yeah most people don't most people think
it's only 16 million
yeah i'm going to be killing it i'm
excited man i'm excited too can't wait i
mean i look i i watched both of you guys
uh
specials and it made me realize like you
know [ __ ] we all have to be
we're all we got you got that right you
know what i mean
yeah we are all we got we can't keep
relying on these
people up in the sky to pluck us out and
put us on a tv show look there there are
good there are good there are good
industry people out there but there's
also there's two or three of them but
it's awesome i would give i would go as
high as six wow but but the problem is
that they have their own game that
they're constantly [ __ ] playing with
each other yes they're engaged in a
constant pissing contest with each other
and the bottom line is it [ __ ] all of
our livelihoods when they decide they
have to be better than when they have to
win
when they're engaged in some where it's
not the same thing for us
it's like our [ __ ] not only gives you a
lifestyle but it doesn't [ __ ] it doesn't
[ __ ] with your lifestyle and when
someone [ __ ] up you only make more
money off of it yeah you know what i
mean when rogan gets called out for
whatever [ __ ] he said
that he only gets more attention when
chappelle gets called out for it and he
said you get more attention like they
find a way to make that a little square
jar first always [ __ ] make money off
of us whereas when they decide to start
going at one another it can [ __ ]
dozens of us to hundreds of us at once
yeah and it's like we're all we got we
gotta just keep making [ __ ] because
that's you're right that's the only way
and uh they're they're morally bankrupt
and they're doing a terrible job we got
to just keep doing our [ __ ] they keep
treating us like the stock market like
if we go up and whatever they're like
we'll buy we'll buy we'll buy but then
when we go down they're like see you
later and you're like no we're human
beings we're people we're artists we're
creators we're trying to make [ __ ] but
they just go
ah you're not doing it the way we like
right now yeah and you're like well
that's not the point that's not the
point it's never been the point yeah i
mean scorsese is a bad movie every now
and then yeah it happens the the biggest
mistake that culture made i don't know i
don't know when it was happened the idea
of giving people what they want
versus giving people what you want
as creators that should be our [ __ ]
up that that should be our honeymoon you
have to get to the point we give you you
have to get to the point where you can
kind of do that but yes that's true but
you get to that point i don't think i
don't think you get to that point by
giving them what they want either
i don't think mean streets is what they
want i think that's what scorsese wanted
yeah exactly
yeah i think that's a good point no i
agree with you i don't think anybody in
this room has ever pandered
we don't we're not amongst panderers
right no no except for this [ __ ] guy
couldn't pass the ball
[Music]
my patrick ewing cutout even though we
have that on camera do we matter
rodney he didn't make it to his 50
because he just kept doing his thing way
older yeah he was older yeah but yeah
you know but legends those days are
[ __ ] i mean look it still happened
but like also we've talked about it too
it's like you want to
you want to enjoy the success it's it's
i know it's kind of [ __ ] up that you
everyone's like he made it when he was
60. that's [ __ ] up he had 20 years to
really enjoy it you know that's that's
kind of a bummer true i mean are you
talking about you talk about norm like i
i i posted this when he died but like my
favorite [ __ ] i will always be
thankful to you for a number of things
but for one was i don't know if you
remember this in 2015 we were doing some
show and at the time i was in l.a
and i was back here
and you were like what are you doing now
and i'm like i don't know and you're
like come with me let's go to the cellar
norm's doing his last he's running his
letterman yes that's right and i was
like [ __ ] okay
and i went and seeing that set changed
me because is that right yeah well he
does his letterman set and it's like you
know it's norm letterman that's great
and then he goes off on this 10 minute
joke about apples oh yeah which i love
that [ __ ] bit but it it you saw how
even at the seller one of the greatest
clubs on the planet
half the audience was still like i don't
know
and the other half was like wow yeah
it's going like a diet it's delicious
that seems like the best one oh dude
it's brilliant the macintosh the old man
macintosh but that's what i'm saying
like oh man it reminded me like oh yeah
what norm did was pure comedy and same
thing patrice did where but norm
like it was like it's not about you this
is about me i'm the performer and it's
your job to get me not my job to play to
you
you come in here you've accepted that
this is a goddamn craft and an art form
and i'm giving you something real and
raw from me yeah and if you can't get it
you're [ __ ] up but i'm putting it in
a way where you can get it i'm giving
you every single opportunity to
understand what this is yeah but i'm not
gonna go further
and then make it about you because it's
not about you yeah i'm not paying to see
you right now meet me in the middle yeah
yeah meet me in the middle and that's
what those guys did amazingly was like
they they gave you such pure real and
they're still little people
you know [ __ ]
chappelle like people get mad at him
like he still does this like he gives it
to you like here it is
it's [ __ ] here i'm giving i'm not
making this hard to understand
you just refuse to
get out of here like well this is about
me nah right
like it's no it's about us as performers
and we're i'm like i know we all
i i know myself personally too i expose
my [ __ ] i'm like there it is i'm
giving you a few like there's my anatomy
chart you know what i mean like it's
what i'm [ __ ] made of if you don't
like it fine i'm not saying
i'm not saying i'm for everyone but i'm
also saying i'm giving you every
opportunity yes yeah right and like
writing joke rodney did it any great
comic does that where they're like this
is pure me yeah and that's the best
you're gonna get and if you need me to
[ __ ] hold your hand i'll walk you out
the [ __ ] door so that i can continue
doing me
and that's what then i'll walk you home
and if you don't like it yeah if you
don't want to let me upstairs and you're
stuck up yeah
yeah let me guess a bunch of [ __ ]
clam chowders
man or new england but that's i don't
know i just i always love that about
norm where it's like man [ __ ] like some
of this [ __ ] i mean it's so goddamn
brilliant you watch his weekend updates
on youtube he's bombing half of it but
that's great
he's ahead of his time he is he is
because at home we were like oh [ __ ] but
in the crowd they're like i don't know
if we're supposed to and you're like oh
come on get [ __ ] even bill burr
oh
monologue and it was great but the crowd
was like can we are we and you're like
it's a comedy show you [ __ ] what are we
doing here
he's making jokes yeah it's edgy or dark
or whatever i love this like can we and
this i i hate all this analyzing like is
that okay well that's not good but he's
got a black wife
well no one knew that i mean i think i
think it was like people have like a
standards and practices in their own
minds like does that fly
trust that guttural reaction that you
have don't don't make this about some
societal rules
laugh or don't laugh it should be
instinct it should be you okay and it is
deep down are you guys finding though
that lately
audiences are back and that's great but
then sometimes i've done a couple shows
lately where i'm like god damn this is
tanking and then afterwards there's a
horde of people wanting to be like oh i
really that was great and i'm like i get
that what the [ __ ] is going on i was
like oh you've spent a year
on like watching
like you're laughing up here now you're
right
kennison used to have a quote where he
would sam kennison would say you know
you don't want to do pretty well with
the whole crowd you want to crush for
three
that was his yeah i did i've never heard
that before and it just gave me a slight
chub yeah when you crush your three you
kind of you're like get three people for
a while you turn the audience you find
the clitoris in the audience
you just gotta stimulate the clitoris it
takes it takes about an hour and a half
too but once you get it once you find
the clitoris
and
oftentimes much like an actual clitoris
they're just slightly to the right
i'm focusing my energy the whole time
and it takes racist jokes to take off
the hood
the torah hood
uh i love the idea of you just shouting
racial slurs into your wife's
soon-to-be
you know you know you know mike
you wanna wait can i throw
oh we got to get out of here all right
one last thing one last thing i just i
gotta plug your weekends and i'll plug
my yes my thing i think my family is
catering mark's wedding that's right
yeah my sister that's exciting yeah
trying to keep it in the fam yeah yeah
dude yeah so
you're officiate i don't know if i told
you that oh
i would love to are you officiating
what's the deal with weddings guys
i'm ordained i'm like oh that's true
half of them don't even work out am i
right guys
yeah yeah you're next you're a first
reader you've seen them on
[Laughter]
oh man i mean tom papa doing rachel
feinstein's wedding killed really so
funny and when quinn goes up and does a
speech after tom papa's and then he
kills shits on tom papa because yeah tom
your minister voice was really pissing
me off and that gets a huge laugh and
then tom goes on after quinn and goes
yeah i should have mumbled through my
speech like you colin it's about them
just a killing bag of boys [ __ ] on
each other yeah
incredible that's great where are you
gonna be mark talk oh hey uh i'm gonna
be all over the place uh this
new year's milwaukee improv come on out
say hello do the whole ball drop
nonsense kansas city improv
uh
[ __ ] in my mouth the syracuse funny bone
oh there's nothing on twitter there's no
dates there we go
this is all wrong my website sucks it
says wes nayak i was there in september
phoenix arizona i was also there in
august even the dates are wrong goes
from 12 to 6.
how'd that happen come on who does your
website this lady she's a pothead
um she's nice i try to throw her a
couple buckhead that's a good theater
yeah that's already passed
how was that was that good that was
great that's in the ninth that's that's
this comes on the 19th
that's december 9th this comes out the
19th
oh [ __ ] this episode sorry sorry sorry
numbers
uh but yeah i'm all over the place i'm
going to update this [ __ ]
we'll get it together i think i'm going
to chicago at some point uh other dates
wait i want to stick to being the truth
sarah it's no it isn't the 19th it's
only the first time today's the first
yeah today we're backlogging because our
schedules are no i get you i get you i'm
just look for you listening to this now
on the 19th if you're shocked that this
was pre-recorded
okay
secondly uh
it's almost 2022 guys i know we lost a
good two years of our lives here and we
might lose more with this omnichrome
well let's let's not get ahead i got
boosted up i'm boosted up let's [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] get that booster guys oh
are you at the heart for funny balls i
am what happened hey my boy trey wingo i
hope i see you there he came to your
show oh good guy espn's finest i love
that he's not there anymore look at the
dimples on that
marcus russell price yeah i'll be at uh
richmond virginia january 20th through
22nd timonia maryland the 29th to 20 uh
27th to 29th hartford funny bone the
11th to 12th of february sacramento the
18th through 20th and uh yeah and uh
[ __ ] beacon theater new york city
should be live may 9th get on that [ __ ]
all right let's talk about google boy
makes good by the way that's a that's
good you want to tune in for these pods
because you're going to be an angry
angry curmudgeon after those three gigs
in a row really hartford magoobies and
sandman we'll see what happens tune in
folks am i oh i am you're going to have
some stories and sacramento is good i
don't think i don't have to get enough
light for any of those gifts
and i do have that i wanted a neck to
heal so yeah let's uh sacramento is a
good time that's a good club that's a
great [ __ ] time man a club hotel buy
out but uh i don't other than that very
good i'm excited
all right out to lunch i hate myself
rooftop uh documentary
uh king scorpio dropping but listen to
scuttlebutt it's out now king scorpio
and be prepared for the special i don't
know when it's coming out
very exciting all right folks thanks a
lot happy holidays kwanzaa hanukkah
praise allah
quit up bro matt how long was that one
that's two hours we're tickling two oh
we're tickling two
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you